okay so this presentation is going to be
on Mendelian genetics you know some of
the history of genetics that we learned
through the work of Gregor Mendel so
let's get started
so our knowledge of genetics really
began with this man right here Gregor
Mendel Gregor Mendel was an Austrian
monk and today we kind of recognize him
as the father of modern genetics because
of this work I'm experimenting with pea
plants this experiment this experiment
with pea plants lasted over seven years
and he literally bred thousands and
thousands of different P plans in order
to learn the basics of heredity so
Mendel experimented with seven different
traits from these tea plants one of the
traits being flower colors the flowers
sometimes grew purple petals and others
grew white petals he examined the flower
position where the flowers in the
terminal position at the tips of the
branches over the flowers in the axial
position you know kind of inward on the
branches the seed color did the seeds
our or the yellow in color or were they
green in color the texture of the seeds
did they have a smooth touch or a kind
of a wrinkled texture to them the color
of the pods or the pads yellow in color
or the pods green in color the shape of
the pods were the where the pods kind of
puffy and inflated or were they
constricted
and lastly the stem height did the pea
plants grow tall or short so these were
the seven traits that Mendel
experimented with and observed and based
on his results which we'll see in a
little bit he uncovered a pattern and
this pattern turned out to be the basics
of genetics and heredity heredity being
the passing of traits from parent to
offspring so let's talk about his work
so let's actually look at how Mendel
conducted his experiment now we
mentioned seven characteristics but
we're going to just look at one we're
going to look at flower color the purple
flowers versus the white flowers so in
the first generation of the experiment
also known as the pea generation the P
stands for the parents he had one parent
with purple flowers and one parent with
white flowers now we tried it both ways
in some experiments the male had purple
flowers and the female had white and in
other experiments it was vice versa and
so what he did was he used a brush he
used a brush to transfer pollen from the
male flower over to the female flower
the female flower grew seeds he
collected the seeds and he planted them
in the garden and when the seeds grew
they became the f1 generation or the
first generation after the parents so in
the f1 generation of Mendel's experiment
100% of the offspring grew purple
flowers and that's kind of interesting
considering one of the parents had white
flowers so what Mendel learned is that
some traits are dominant and some traits
are recessive notice how the white trait
was hidden or covered this is the
recessive trait and purple is the
dominant trait because it appears to be
hiding the expression of the white so
now Mendel moves on with his experiment
he allowed the plans of the f1
generation to self pollinate he
transferred pollen from the male parts
to its own female parts
plants often have male and female parts
and
pollinate themselves and so then he
collected the seeds of the f1 generation
grew them in his garden and allowed them
to grow and this became the f2
generation and what he noticed as the
flowers grew was for every three that
had purple flowers one would have light
so 75% grew purple flowers 25% grew
white and so what Mendel uncovered is
that offspring don't always resemble
their parents notice the parents of the
f1 generation were all purple and yet
25% of the f2 generation had white
flowers he also noticed that traits can
skip generations
notice how the presence of white flowers
was skipped in the f1 generation moment
this is because white is recessive
now Mendel examined again seven total
traits and so four flower color here are
his hairs his data he counted 705 plants
with purple flowers 224 plants with
white flowers so as we said a moment ago
for every three that grew purple flowers
one grew white this is a three to one
ratio for the other traits he counted
6022 plants with yellow seeds in 2001
with green seeds again a three to one
ratio when he examined the height of the
stem 787 with tall stems 277 with short
stems again almost a three-to-one ratio
when he examined the pod color 428
plants head green pods 152 head yellow
pods again almost the three-to-one ratio
when he examined the texture of the
seeds 5474 with smooth 1,850 with
wrinkled again almost the three-to-one
ratio when he examined the shape of the
pods 882 with inflated pods 299 with
constricted pods almost a three-to-one
ratio and then for flower position 705
flower plants with flowers in the
terminal position 224 in the axial
position almost a three to one ratio
notice the pattern he figured there has
to be a mathematical
explanation for it and you'll see what
that is in just a few moments and as a
result of Mendel's work here there is
what is now known as Mendel's laws
remember this experiment here using the
painters brush he transferred pollen
from a flower that had purple petals he
transferred pollen to a female with
white petals and 100% of the f1
generation was purple so this is what is
known as the law of dominance purple
appears to be dominant to white purple
is preventing the expression of white so
this is the law of dominance is that
genes can be dominant and recessive
another law that Vendela cun covered is
what is known as the law of independent
assortment and that just says that genes
are sorted independent of one another
therefore if the flaut there was no
connection between the flower color and
the seed texture the pod color had
nothing to do with the seed color the
seed color had nothing to do with the
texture and so all of these different
traits were independent of one another
and then finally the law of segregation
offspring inherit one gene copy from
each parent but we all have two parents
so that means we have two copies of
every gene in our DNA for instance the
purple flower on the Left has two copies
of the purple gene on the right the
white flower has two copies of the white
teen but the offspring in the middle
receives one from each parent this is
the law of segregation the genes are
segregated during chromosome F formation
and during the process of meiosis and
the formation of eggs and sperms so this
is the law of segregation is that the
offspring only inherit one copy from
each parent
so as we go through our genetics unit we
need to understand some vocabulary and
one of the most important words would be
the word an allele and alternate form of
a gene you know for instance in flower
color the gene for flower color comes in
two forms form number one can be purple
and form number two can be white so
there's two forms of this gene you know
the gene for pod color comes in two
forms one form green one form yellow
there's an allele for green there's an
allele for yellow you know for human
blood type is actually three alleles
that determine the human blood type you
know one per you might have an A allele
we might have a B allele you might also
have an O allele and so the combination
of alleles that we inherit determine our
blood type and so alleles make up our
genotype now we have two parents and so
we get an allele one allele from mom and
one allele from dad the combination of
those two alleles determines our
genotype so if in the animation here the
offspring just received the dominant
purple allele from the parents on the
left and a dominant purple allele from
the parent on the right and because
purple was dominant
notice how I use capital letters capital
letters are used to represent dominant
alleles and anytime you an individual
inherits two dominant alleles one from
the mother one from the father we call
this combination homozygous dominant
well what about if you were to look at a
white flowered example remember white
was a recessive color so we're using
lowercase letters now so in this case
the parent on the left just passed on a
recessive allele to the offspring and
now the parent on the right is passing
on a recessive allele to the offspring
if you inherit two recessive alleles
this combination is called homozygous
recessive
and so then the only other possibility
is what if you receive a dominant allele
from one parent and the recessive allele
from the other pair remember purple is
dominant so I'm going to use a capital
letter for purple and white was
recessive so I'm going to use a
lowercase letter for white so the
offspring is inherited a dominant and a
recessive allele this combination is
known as heterozygous so the this
genotype is known as heterozygous so
there are three possible genotypes a
person or an individual can inherit two
dominant allele that's called that
genotype was called homozygous dominant
an individual can inherit one dominant
and one recessive allele that's called
heterozygous and an individual can
inherit two recessive alleles
that's called homozygous recessive now
another vocabulary word we need to
understand is the word phenotype the
physical expression of a gene notice how
there are two two of the three options
are for the color purple purple is the
phenotype notice how all it takes is one
dominant allele to show the color purple
because purple is dominant and white is
recessive and so the phenotype for the
bottom option the phenotype for the
lowercase P lowercase P would be white
so again the phenotype is what is
physically expressed in this case purple
flowers and white flowers are physically
expressed okay so here is a few review
questions you know you have ten choices
pause the video and see how many of
these choices apply to number one and
then how many apply to number two and
how many apply to number three I'm going
to go over the answers in three two one
okay so for number one which choices are
genotypes I hope you said the answers of
one three five six seven and ten all the
letter combinations are genotypes for
number two which choices are
heterozygous genotypes well there's only
two answers number three and number six
now typically you put the capital letter
first but anytime there's a combination
of one dominant and one recessive allele
that's a heterozygous genotype and then
number three which choice our choices
are phenotypes I hope you said two four
eight and nine the physical descriptions
are phenotypes so now I want to show you
how we can use Mendel's work in solving
punnett squares punnett squares if you
recall our genetic tools that we use to
predict offspring probabilities and in
middle school when you've done punnett
squares number they kind of look like
this four squares to fill in and so
let's show you how to set up a punnett
square
so the genotype of the parents we're
going to place on the outside of the
punnett square and remember in this
example where we had a purple and a
white P generation of the parent one
parent was purple flowers one parent had
white flowers and 100% of the f1
generation had purple flower petals this
is because purple was dominant and white
was recession but I want to show you how
we can mathematically explain this in
the punnett square the way that Mendel
bread his Peas he was confident that the
purple the purple parents of the pea
generation was pure or homozygous
dominant and also the white parent was
pure or homozygous recessive so the
first thing we do is we put these
genotypes on the outside of the punnett
square the next thing we do is we simply
fill in each of the four squares with
the letters
and once we do we're going to have a
genotype inside each of the four punnett
squares inside the squares this
represents the offsprings genotype and
notice the square in the top left is
going to grow purple flowers the square
in the top right is going to grow purple
flowers the square in the lower left
will grow purple flowers the square in
the lower right will grow purple flowers
100% of those of those punnett squares
are going to go purple because they have
a purple dominant allele inside that
matches the observation that Mendel
obtained in his experiments and then if
you recall then if you recall in the f2
generation 75% grew purple flowers and
25% grew white flowers let's see if we
can mathematically explain this with a
punnett square so if you recall this is
where they the plants were self
pollinated so pollen was transferred to
the female part of the same flower that
means both parents or heterozygous
capital P lowercase P and so when we
fill in the punnett square I hope you'll
see how we can mathematically explain
the results that Mendel obtained the
punnett square in the upper left is
going to grow purple flowers because the
purple dominant alleles are possessed in
that punnett square in the top right
they will also grow purple flowers the
lower left purple flowers notice the
only one that does not grow purple
flowers is the square in the lower right
hand corner so three squares out of four
or 75% of the squares will grow purple
flowers and 25% will grow grow white
flowers this is exactly what Mendel
discovered in his experiments
okay so here's a practice problem that I
want you to try to solve pause the video
try to solve it I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one
so the story says one parent is
heterozygous yellow and the other parent
is homozygous recessive green so now I
can fill in my punnett squares and from
the inside of the punnett squares I can
use the results to answer questions 1 2
3 & 4 so for number one list the
offspring genotypes well notice how two
of them are heterozygous and two of them
are homozygous recessive for number two
list the offspring phenotypes phenotypes
are what we physically see so two out of
the four squares would grow yellow two
out of the four squares would grow green
for number three what's the probability
of growing a homozygous dominant plant
the answer is zero homozygous dominant
in this punnett square does not exist
that would be to capital wise there are
no squares with to capital wise and
number four what's the probability of
growing yellow seeds in this punnett
square the answer is 50%
and so there you have it if you're in my
biology class you know pause the video
try to answer these questions and I'm
happy to check your answers before
school or after school and you know
leave your comments in the box below I
hope you found this video helpful